da tief präpositionen mit von nach aus
bei zu seit gegenüber ab
mit wem hast du telefoniert
ich habe mit meiner freundin telefoniert
ich habe mit meinem vater telefoniert
ich habe
mit meinem vater telefoniert
mit wem hast du telefoniert
ich habe mit meiner mutter telefoniert
wovon träumst du
ich träume von einem haus am strand
ich träume von neuen schuhen
ich träume von einem hund
ich träume von einer
und
wonach suchen sie
ich suche nach einem schönen rock
ich suche nach warmen stiefeln
wonach suchen sie
ich suche nach einer tollen jacke
ich suche nach
jacke
woher kommst du
ich komme aus dem sudan
ich komme aus der schweiz
[Musik]
ich komme aus italien
ich komme aus den usa
[Musik]
wo warst du
ich war bei meinem bruder
[Musik]
ich war bei tina
wo warst du
ich war bei meiner schwester
ich war bei
bester
ich war beim arzt
ich war
beim arzt
gehst du
ich gehe zum bahnhof
ich gehe zur apotheke
wo
gehst du
ich gehe zum rathaus
ich gehe zu da
ich gehe zu daniel
seit wann lebst du in der schweiz
ich lebe seit einer woche in der schweiz
ich lebe seit drei monaten in der
schweiz
ich lebe
seit fünf jahren in der schweiz ich lebe
seit fünf jahren in der schweiz
wo wohnen sie
[Musik]
ohne gegenüber dem kino
ich wohne gegenüber dem kino
ich wohne gegenüber der kirche
wohne gegenüber dem supermarkt
ich wohne gegenüber dem supermarkt
wann willst du mit dem rauchen aufhören
ich werde ab nächster woche nicht mehr
rauchen
ich werde ab montag nicht mehr rauchen
ich werde ab dem nächsten jahr nicht
mehr rauchen
akkusativ präpositionen durch für bis
ohne gegen um
was hat der dieb gemacht
er ist durch das fenster eingebrochen
er ist durch den tunnel geflohen
wo
hast du dich
ich interessiere mich für die musik
ich interessiere mich für das reisen
[Musik]
ich interessiere mich für den goldkurs
ich interessiere mich für den
deutschkurs
muss ich die steuern bezahlen
sie müssen die steuern bis morgen
bezahlen
sie müssen die steuern bis nächste woche
sie müssen die steuern bis nächsten
monat bezahlen
kommst du allein zum fest ja ich komme
ohne meine freundin
ja ich komme ohne meine freundin
ja ich komme ohne meinen mann
wogegen demonstriert du
ich demonstriere gegen die tierversuche
ich demonstriere gegen die regierung
wo
um kümmerst du dich ich kümmere mich um
die pflanze
ich kümmere mich um die pflanze
ich kümmere
um das schwein
ich kümmere mich um das schwein
ich kümmere mich um den garten
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal